beautiful picture welcome back to gary
in live ops after some time off so this
is a view from our camera on top of the
rio so it's looking across the strip
it's looking past caesar's palace at the
high roller at the link not jiggling
around so much right now but through
much of the overnight hours it really
has been whipped you probably heard it
at home during the overnight hours maybe
it disrupted your sleep we do have some
high clouds officially we're hanging at
82 degrees the weather headlines looking
like this the wind advisory expired at
five this morning we have a temperature
roller coaster this week we're going to
be bouncing between the 90s and the low
100s and what late week storm clouds
don't hold your breath waiting for that
so over the next couple of hours we're
going to be back to 83 at 8 87 at noon
mid 90's at 3 going for a high of 98
this afternoon but the big deal is going
to be the wind southwesterly at 30 most
of the day maybe backing off a little
bit at 6 p.m neighborhood temperatures
now 77 is the cool spot if you want to
call it that up at the summerlin area
but do watch out for those gusty winds
coming from the southwest going to stay
that way throughout the day 87s along
the east side from nellis to sunrise
mountain down to henderson take away one
for green valley along the strip at 82
to nevada and beyond much cooler up in
ealy white pine county could see a
trailing shower today cedar city you're
at 67 turn that around 76 over the hump
in peru so after three days in a row of
way above normal temperature two days at
109 set a record high on friday tied the
record high on saturday yesterday 106.
we're going for 98 today a degree below
normal our current temperature in 80 the
low so far still windy today for your
family and friends across the country
scattered showers in the pacific
northwest severe storms moving fairly
rapidly through the dakotas into
minnesota here's your eight day forecast
after the strong gusty winds well
they're going to shift directions but
still gusting to 30 tomorrow 96 the high
and then back to triple digits for a few
days 106 thursday watch for clouds to
come in we're not guaranteeing rain by
any means some storm clouds late in the
week